julia in seattle starts this hour off
hi julia how are you hey you doing good
dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up uh so
quick question um earlier this year i
started baby steps two and three at this
hello okay i know so try it one more
time they're saying all right let's try
one more time joe you with me still
can you hear me okay earlier in the year
you started baby steps two and three at
the same time
yes and then i once i discovered you yep
i wanted to
tackle my debt instead um but now that i
do have
um so i have six thousand saved in an
emergency fund
but i have eight thousand dollars in
credit card debt and six thousand
in student loans so my question is
should i transfer a portion of that
emergency fund to just start
tackling that debt or do you think i
should keep
the emergency fund where it's at just in
case well if you're going to do our plan
we teach you to keep one thousand
dollars as baby step one
apply everything else in your debt
snowball in baby step two that is not
in a retirement account investments or
other cash or anything you can get your
hands on
to push your way through baby step two
as fast as possible
as soon as baby step two is done we
return to the one thousand dollar
account
and that's called baby step three and
raise it up to
three to six months of expenses so you
said you had six thousand dollars saved
yes so doing it our way you'd pull five
of that and you would throw it at your
smallest debt which i think i heard was
your student loan
yes it's my student loan it's the credit
card the one that i'm really mad at but
um yeah student loan review debts
um these are my only two debts um but
the credit card started out at fifteen
thousand dollars and so it's been the
biggest um
the biggest one that i've been trying to
knock down yeah but the point is i mean
you got
six and eight is fourteen minus five is
nine
you should pay off nine making a hundred
and thirty thousand in about twenty
minutes
you need to knock these other two out
really really fast
i'm talking about yeah maybe maybe maybe
a month and a half
right yep i can get the credit card
knocked out at the end of january
um i should be able to tackle the other
ones early february
the other one is the student loan right
it was smaller
yes it's smaller okay you keep trying to
do this your way let me try it again
okay my way is you list your debts
smallest to largest
you attack them in order you have a six
thousand dollar student loan
it's a one thousand dollar student loan
after this discussion because we're
applying five of your six thousand
dollar savings account to it did i miss
something
okay then you've got eight thousand so
you have nine thousand dollars left
total one in student loans eight in
credit cards and you still
should be done by the end of january
with both of them
okay if you can't do nine thousand
dollars making 135 in two months
something's slipping
right it's mainly my income but uh it's
just we're we're not married so
um oh then that's not a household income
oh sorry about that yeah so it's just my
uh okay well 85
might make it you know it might be the
end of march before you get there
so hey thanks for calling we appreciate
you joining us open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five ken it
is always good to think
okay some people listening to this show
have been listening ten years
and some have been listening ten minutes
and uh
the stuff that you're about the path to
your dream job you have a very clear
path to get there the path to wealth we
have a very clear path to get there
called the
baby steps and we really don't need to
change those because they work
they work they work because they are
practical they work because they
are sequential they build on each other
so it's so important when you get that
emergency fund you've got that kind of
rainy day if something happens it's a
thousand dollars in the bank and now we
can go with gazelle intensity
to knock those off and this this lady
here is going to be in great shape
uh in you know three to six months she's
gonna be working on that baby step three
and getting that
that true rainy day fund there to three
to six months expenses where you can
breathe easy
and there's a reason why it works over
time there is a tested process
the same thing with finding what you
were created to do you got to get clear
you can't just well i got all these
ideas no we've got to know
and what are we basing that on and we're
going to base it on god-given gifts
talent that's what you do best passion
work that you love to do you just
love the work high emotion when you
think about it and high devotion to
really do it well
and then mission the results you want to
create so when we say things like
this is the process it is for two
reasons the recipe
it it does work and then my wife works
great pot roast
yeah for 38 years of our marriage yeah
don't change the recipe don't need to my
mouth is watering
right now i know i'm telling you don't
change the recipe
no and don't you know oh i just didn't i
didn't pick up something at the start
you know don't change
it works right work the recipe yeah
work the recipe and so we're always
going to take you back there sometimes
if we think you're
fairly new like our last caller we'll do
so gently
but if you call me up i've been
listening to 10 years and then you asked
me that same question i'm probably going
to smack you around verbally
because you don't need to be asking that
question if you've been listening ten
years you know
you will smack them around verbally dave
don't give these folks
this idea that i might not go easy on
them if they've been 10 years listening
yeah dave i've listened to you for 10
years and i just leased a car and went
down to the payday lender
and i don't believe in budgeting so what
do you think i should do right you
should probably listen to a different
show
so what is that what is the human
element what is it about us that
we okay i know dave's got this show i
know he's helped a lot of people
i've listened to him long enough you
know we make fun of the
some of the left-wing millennials or
whatever call them snowflakes but in at
the end of the day inside of every one
of us we all think we're
snowflake we all think we're unique huh
yeah we all think that that well maybe
it doesn't apply to me maybe maybe if i
want to lose weight i don't have to
exercise more and eat less maybe there's
a maybe i can just take a pill
yeah maybe for me there's a different
formula for losing weight so i'm going
to run this bike
calorie intake stay back away
from the doughnuts this true it is true
eating healthy and exercising is
guaranteed to improve your health and
help you lose weight there's no way
around that
you know what i mean there's no free you
know what the other thing too is there's
nobody you can't buy crap on an
infomercial and your thigh master is not
gonna do it i'm just saying
yeah i remember those when those first
came out if you wore this belt
it would vibrate on your stomach and eat
away at the fat and i always remember
going who's going to buy that but
apparently a lot
of people bought a lot of people because
it involved not paying no pain and no
sacrifice to hit their goal yeah
and by the way when it's that easy
you're never going to stick with it oh
and let me help you with this too it
didn't work
there's always that there's always that
get rich quick
it doesn't work sacrifice involved
follow the recipe
follow the recipe